[Music]
how
[Music]
do do
ah delicious canned water
all right how are people doing
i hope everyone's doing all right
sorry that filled that up quite a bit uh
hello gozer carowind rowan ian
is wicked wolf uh
db lots of folks in good to see you all
hi pirates
uh you you are so
doubting miss wicked wolf you you don't
seem to trust me at all
i don't i don't understand why not
ah
so hope everybody is
i'm doing all right ben
um there isn't like a deep meaning or
anything
by the um by the title
for this particular live stream it's
just kind of my mood
and it's frustrating because i appear to
have been
uh forgotten lately by the algorithms on
both youtube and tick tock they seem to
have both decided oh
she just doesn't exist anymore
as far as we're concerned just keep
having things
um underperforming or
flat out tanking and it's frustrating a
little bit
a little bit hello there an
odd idea finally caught your live stream
i'm always delighted to see your videos
thank you thank you very much i remember
forsaken was a weird n64 game
yeah that game i never played it i
remember the box art
for forsaken though which
made no sense oh so ms wicked wolf
why do i hate april fool's day because
april fool's day might as well
be renamed to national [ __ ] day
that's why because
look i hate pranks
as a style of humor i'm not going to say
there is no such thing
as a good prank but
the number of good pranks or ones that i
think are any good
and i don't think are horrible terrible
things
is a vast minority the vast majority of
pranks rely on making other people
in some way very upset without their
consent to the situation and
screw you that's not funny that's cruel
you think it's funny
but screw you like about the only thing
i'll give a pass
to i'll give a pass to things like say
jackass
where the whole cast are doing these
things to each other and like
they have literally signed contracts
agreeing that they're
okay with this going on so
like that i'll give a pass to but that
is
honestly about it
and even that i don't particularly find
funny i just don't
judge it quite as hard um
finally found me on tick tock and you
also know my real name i do doesn't mean
i'm gonna use it here
because a trying to remember names and
keep everything straight is
iffy for me and b you have the right to
not use your real name here so i'm not
gonna out you for that
who's your favorite character from the
office i don't like the office
i watched the first season of the us
version
and um no it was good
i i was upset i'd had my phil i didn't
hate it but i didn't like it especially
we reckon the algorithm trouble is due
to you not making enough animal
sacrifices to the internet gods
okay last i knew humans still counted as
animals so
are you saying that they've now narrowed
the definition and human sacrifices to
the internet gods are no longer
acceptable because i have a problem
killing animals i'm not comfortable with
it
uh
i think the last two years has mostly
stopped april fool's day good
kill it forever someone pranked me
telling me that my favorite celebrity
died i cried before they told me it was
a prank i
blocked them good absolutely perfect
i um i
almost decked
one of my suite mates my third year at
college
um when they pulled prank [ __ ] on me
like when they when like the whole lot
of them when they realize how pissed i
was they all scattered and i managed to
get my hands on one of them and shoved
him up against the wall
i um i think he thought i was gonna eat
his face
i was pissed and they didn't pull that
[ __ ] again they doesn't really talk to
me again after that i think they decided
i wasn't any fun
because i called them on their [ __ ] um
i thought national [ __ ] day was when
people celebrate straight pride
no because we don't recognize that to
call that national [ __ ] day means
we're recognizing it as a thing
and we're not gonna do that
uh remember when you told everyone on
twitch
that i like to poke poke at you with
glee yes
yes i do because you do
thoughts on doctor doom he is a great
character that for
some reason
nobody outside of comics seems to get
like at all
i was really kind of curious and
um excited about the idea of noah holly
doing
a doom movie but that seems to have been
scrapped with the
with the fox buyout but
you know doom is doom is
in my mind an ideal long-running
villain and maybe that's part of the
problem with
why he adapts so poorly
to film especially
because film when it comes to uh
its villains really does do best on one
and dones
by and large and if you're gonna have a
recurring villain
it can be hard to have them keep being a
villain
the like the whole thing with
dr doom is that he works
amazingly well as a long running he's
out there somewhere doing something and
so when he turns up it doesn't
necessarily feel as contrived as when
other long-running villains turn up
because
just the kind of guy he is he is always
scheming
and so when he turns out to be behind
something you're like no that tracks
if you thought this was going gonna get
you more power this is totally something
that you would do
and he already has the resources to pull
off
so much stuff and i find him a really
interesting character but because
you can't bring those elements of him
out
in a film that also has to has to have
him lose by the end credits
i think that's part of what throws off
the adaptations in a big part of why
his movie incarnations suck
so hard do you like the band nirvana um
not as much as i'm supposed to given the
generation i come from
i i like some nirvana i appreciate
nirvana i understand the significance of
nirvana
i don't listen to nirvana for fun
never have excuse me i didn't back when
they first became a thing and i don't
know
been doing a reverse watch through of
christopher nolan films
uh this viewing of the dark knight i
finally understood by lucius fox
was still at wayne pry and wayne
enterprises in the next film
oh care to enlighten us then rowan
because actually that's not
of of my issues with uh the the dark
knight
rises uh that was not at the top of my
list
what about a doctor doom series to flesh
out the character
and the land of latvia sorry uh for the
misspell well
like here you have the inherent problem
of trying to
bolster a film with supplementary
material with that which is
more people are going to watch the movie
than the show and
i don't i'm not comfortable
with film studios providing
an incomplete experience because
you didn't consume enough media if
you're going to sell me something
you're going to ask me to pay for it i
should be able to get satisfaction
out of that thing unless it is
explicitly sold to me as part of a set
so like a single episode of a tv show
tv so tv show doesn't have to satisfy me
the way say a film does but i would
expect
a season of a show to bring me some
degree of satisfaction
but to to have like i think the really
good example of this right now
that's semi-topical is rise of skywalker
apparently there are answers to a whole
lot of the logistical
holes in that movie especially where
where
uh it regards palpatine but none of them
are in the movie they're in freaking
comic books and tie-ins and novels and
like
screw you if it's essential information
it needs to be in the movie
and if you can't make the movie work and
cram that in then come up with a
different plan for what to do with your
movie
out of classic who villains that have
been brought into the new series which
ones
have been done the most justice in which
have been the worst done
i don't think any of them have been
badly done uh if i'm gonna be completely
honest
i you know the ones that have come back
the most
have had more opportunities to have flub
episodes but i don't think any
have been flattened out flat out badly
done
uh if i were gonna critique any of them
the one i'd probably have the most
notes for at this point um
would be uh
would be the santorans now that one's a
weird one because when they first showed
back up
in the two-parter in series four great
that was a great reinvention of them
uh unfortunately at this point the
centaurus had become inextricably linked
to strax and strikes as the comedy
character so now
the impression is the centaurons as a
race are now a joke
and are not
they're not uh
they're they're not a threat anymore
they're a punchline and that's a shame
and i do like strikes but they need to
they need to have a story of the
santarans
without him and without that actor
playing
the the santarans i think
uh because he said he was gonna resign
if that sonar machine was there
completely overlooked that he smiles
after blowing it up oh yeah okay that
tracks
oh hi jesse i didn't see you come in
i can't get no doo doo doo
satisfaction
[Music]
there was a guy in my high school who
looks so much like kurt cobain it was
unsettling
i didn't have anybody in my high school
who looked like him i did have a few
people who could sing like him
disturbingly accurately
are you aware of the tiger lilies uh
i'm i have heard of the tiger lilies i
don't know if i've heard any of their
stuff
um but i've heard of them
ah how's things
um tiring
like i got what i had planned to get
done finished today but i'm
i'm wiped like more than i should be and
i don't know
why but
[Music]
it's just kind of a just kind of drained
uh thank god chibnall is bringing back
santorans with intimidating classic
style gear and everything
i don't know story details though oh is
he
this is the thing i don't pay attention
to the to the leaks and the oh this is
coming back
like cause i would rather be surprised
you know i i'm not i'm not a i'm not a
leaks and rumor
tracker person thing
uh did you know that tim curry played
the prosecutor in the 1990 burling
concert version of the wall i did not
[Laughter]
oh
the crown will plainly show
the prisoner was caught red-handed
showing
feelings
uh what do you think of the upcoming
series loki
i'm curious about it it looks fun um
we'll see how it actually ends up
turning out i i mean
so far i have a little bit uh
more confidence in falcon in the winter
soldier than i did
um by the end of one division which i
was a little let down oh
stephen oh okay i need to say this
before i forget it
ah
so steven partridge
is in the chat and starting
this thursday correct me if i'm wrong
stephen i i might be i'm
hydrating
there is going to be a streamed
uh d d game that stephen is
dming for this is going to be on twitch
and this is going to be on his twitch
stream
which is partridge quill
and he's dming it and it's
the the four players and are authors
so four authors are going to be doing a
um a dm uh is going to be doing a dnd
campaign on twitch and they are going to
be archived on i believe sword
and quill is the youtube channel that's
been set up to archive that
i am really really uh excited
about this and actually you know what
i'm gonna try and do something here
so i
i have not gotten to play
dungeons and dragons in a while
um and i am really excited to um
to be able to get to do this and i
want to tease you folks just a little
bit here so let me see if i can
pull up what i'm after um
okay that's what i want all right see if
i can get this up
all right just a moment i'm gonna show
you
a silhouette for
my character so
give me a second here let me just
get it pulled up and assuming that i can
get
this uh thing to you know
work right
um
every time i mess around with technology
it
it
finds ways to bite me in the ass but
anyways
um i'm really excited and
steven is stephen has a lot of homebrew
rule
rules on this okay here we go
so this over in the corner let's see if
i can
blow that up a little bit
all right that folks
oh goodness sake i'm sorry i'm watching
my mother's dog and
he's an idiot
so uh that is the silhouette
for the character i will be playing
um and i am
really really excited for this
so that's the little tease i'm gonna
give you uh
a bit of seder people asking bard seder
looks like fun bard sater bart
uh it i am uh
i'm looking forward to this a lot oh are
you are you kidding me
are you he just brought over this
freaking
hedgehog because he wants me to throw it
like this is a very awkward angle i
can't really get it out the door
from where i'm sitting and the room is
small and
ah he is ah here's a [ __ ]
uh the twitch name again so this
thursday and it's gonna be bi-weekly so
every two weeks
um and um
the the twitch channel is
uh uh steven partridge
i'm gonna get that cleared off there we
go um
so that starts on thursday and oh
goodness sake orion
just barely managed to get that out the
door um so every two weeks
uh and and i will i will um
like i'll drop notes on on twitter and
in the
community tabs on uh the youtube channel
and things like that
oh
yeah so forgive me as i have to
intermittently reach down pick up this
gross slobbery hedgehog
to throw get out of here
uh he's been sleeping all day and now we
now he wants to play huh
a bit of a tease in a couple ways to be
honest oh really
uh last time i played d and d
i was a time mage celestial who
basically acted
uh like insane seventh doctor
like i have my notions for how my
character's gonna play but like a lot of
it is going to be found
in the um in the interactions and in the
act of
playing them so um been getting into any
big finish lately no
because i'm trying to catch up on other
stuff
i'm i am trying
desperately to um
get everything that i've been trying to
get done and had hoped to have done
earlier in this year
um completed and lined up
so like i it is my goal
to have my novel available for
digital pre-order later this month
and hopefully physical pre-order not too
long after that
and i've started working with uh the
narrator on
the audiobook and i'm a little less than
halfway through the finalized edit um
as soon as that's done i need to get
advanced reader copies out
it's and then i need i'd like
once it's truly finalized i need to get
copies to the
kickstarter backers like this is a lot
it's a lot uh
can we see the dog um he has wandered
off again
so if he comes back
i'll let you see the dog but for right
now
he seems to be done playing for the time
being so we're going to let him be
did you know that in the comics the
howling commandos our team
are a team of marvel's version of movie
monsters like frankenstein's monster and
wolf man and the mummy
uh is that a recent development because
like i feel like you're pulling my leg
you're either pulling my leg
or that only recently happened
i say recently like after their main
thing
the narrator sounds like it could be a
doctor who villain oh it does doesn't it
never winter is a good online dungeon
dragons game i remember trying to get
into that one i didn't get very far
moulin rouge is on broadway would you go
see it no
uh i play one game and uh dm
another i play a half elf
ranger who was brought up in a circus
it's very theatrical and quite ambiguous
[Laughter]
i i am i'm legitimately very excited
um about getting to do this i i just i
haven't gotten to
to do this kind of gaming in ages uh
also in that concert albert finney was
the judge
so it was an annie reunion the evidence
before the court is in incontrovertible
just started the eric roberts master
series that's quite good i've heard good
things and i'm definitely curious
but like much like with everything else
i have a backlog
a big finished stuff that i've already
bought and haven't
or has been sent to me as gifts and i
haven't listened to
so you know trying to justify catching
up on the new stuff
uh do you like the song blinding lights
by the weekend yes
actually i like that song quite a bit
i found out about it because it was a
tick top tick
tock meme a few months back um
i think you'll see invincible if time
allows i would recommend
i was talking with caroline
about that earlier today that
like it was a show that i was prepared
to pass on but
everybody's saying that's really good
and i'm just kind of like
fine i guess i'll watch the show that
everyone
says is good and i would like fine
and just being spiteful at the
possibility of
of getting to see something that i will
probably enjoy
but just the idea of more
things to do just
[Laughter]
i haven't watched doctor who since
angels take manhattan is it still
good matt or has it gone downhill i mean
swings and roundabouts as a show it has
its ups and downs it has definitely been
very good since then um
it's not at one of its high points right
now
but like there's definitely been
stretches since then that i think are
well worth watching
uh why won't you go see moulin rouge on
broadway because i don't
like it and i think you know
that uh
is one of the ones on the backlog
masterful i don't even think i've gotten
to that one yet because the backlog
predates that have you watched anything
featuring jody whitaker outside of
doctor who i think the
um yes because i've seen the first
season of broadchurch
and i've seen the um the black mirror
episode she was in which was
ah i remember what it was about i can't
remember what it was called now
but those are the other things i've seen
her in
it's not inspired by doctor who but
there is a character in a series i'm
writing
who's simply known as the associate see
now that to me
sounds like an assassin
uh if they cast you in the wizard of oz
remake would you do it only if i can
play the scarecrow
if i only had a brain
uh have you played the new among us map
yet no
i did not realize there was a new map oh
i've touched that game in a month or two
um
have you seen any of the japanese
godzilla films a smattering of them
like a very random smattering i've seen
like
i've seen final wars i've seen
godzilla versus i've
versus king kong i've seen
um son of godzilla i've seen godzilla
versus megalon i've seen godzilla versus
violante
um i think those are the only ones i've
seen
front to back all the way through
um there are other ones that i've see
that like i've seen
bits of like i've seen most of shin
godzilla just not in order
uh the major issue i have with the wall
is that i
don't really care for roger waters as a
person he seems
very up himself and really ruined pink
floyd as it went on
i mean there's definitely an
argument to be made there um like here's
here's what i will say about roger
waters and his time
on pink floyd
um i feel like
what would have been really what should
have happened what
what it feels like should have happened
is that
once the wall was over
that should have kind of been an
expunging
of his daddy issues and
his wrestling with fame not to say that
he could never touch on those themes
again but they should never have been
front and center again you got a whole
album
uh to be front and center with that so
move on to other stuff but then the fact
that the final cut
came out after that and was dealing with
all the same
stuff that was kind of where i was like
dude
come on so yeah like i love the wall
i love it a lot i'm not a
[Music]
huge uh
fan of um a lot of the other work
when he was there
i like some of it like dark side of the
moon's still good
but a lot of the rest is kind of mixed
and thank you
uh carowind for dealing with the trolls
they seem to have
popped up again as they do
intermittently
pirates looks like you uh you nailed one
too
so um yeah cheers to the mods
thank you kindly
i for one think that invincible is way
better than the boys because
it's not a superhero core and raunch
fest
sorry about the anger just venting i
mean
the boys is based off garth ennis and
you know it's going to be kind of
tri-hardy
edgelord ish what did you do for
easter just um the standard
family stuff that i do
uh forgive me for not going into detail
on that but
uh i don't get into that much of what
i do with my family on here so we're
gonna leave it at that
it's very important that you listen to
missy volume two before masterful
good to know cause i i am gonna get to
those
eventually um
your favorite song and dance
uh man or woman excluding bugs bunny
um song and dance person
um
i mean
it's really kind of hard to beat gene
kelly
or fred astaire maybe ginger rogers
like you don't get song and dance
people today the way that you did it's
just not quite the same
um although you know gregory heinz
he was good uh does your daughter
believe in the easter bunny i don't
know
she might but
um i mean we still we still talk as if
she does but i mean obviously there
isn't as much wrapped up in that
as um as santa
uh thoughts on space jam 2 trailer i
literally have no thoughts on that
trailer
it was a thing that i watched
i have no nostalgia for the original
space jam
i don't watch basketball i know who
lebron james is but i
don't care i like the looney tunes but i
don't
care about this it i don't
it doesn't even get enough of a reaction
on me for me to say it doesn't look good
i just
don't care
about the only thing that got any kind
of reaction out of me at
all was
um when like
they went from being 2d to being 3d
modeled and i just tilted my head and
went
why why would you do that
like that i don't get
excuse me
uh to be fair with pink floyd lots of
bands are criticized by fans when they
switch up style or themes like green day
going back to garage rock in the early
tens and people hating
i mean like i i understand that it is
difficult
to um
to move on from themes
especially in terms of fan reaction but
like
the final cut is just a worse version of
the wall
and that previous one felt so personal
and the final cut
feels so manufactured
i just uh
i like space jam because it's such a 90s
time capsule i mean if you've got
nostalgia for the 90s that
is that is valid
todd in the shadows does a series on bad
career ending albums called train
records
i think the final cut would be a good
one to go into
well did roger waters leave after that
one or was it later and i do watch todd
in the shadows and i do like that series
um like especially because
i don't i don't dig that much into like
what goes on behind the scenes with
music stuff so to to get a perspective
from his
that is as entertaining
as he manages to be i i enjoy his stuff
in general
um
uh and you'd be right there's a
crap ton more to the character but you'd
be right sorry randomness i am not
i'm no longer sure what what is being
referred to there
i'm only interested in the new space gym
because
fluffy is speedy i
okay are those words i am supposed to
be able to parse i i think i'll just
[Music]
uh
yeah mods you can just um
actually question for the mods do you
have the ability to
um just ban them um
or is it only the time out because
if you have the option hide user on this
channel
for the people who you've had to time
out more than once just go ahead and do
that
they won't be back on that account after
that
it'll save it'll save you from having to
keep timing out the same people over and
over and over again
so you if if you were holding back
because um you thought that
uh maybe maybe it was an overstep no
you have my blessing what happened oh
well you see leprechaun i i'm seeing
the um the messages a lot of which are
just getting automatically held for
review so you
folks on the chat aren't um seeing them
at all
um but
i like i'm seeing them so i'm i'm seeing
the work
that the mods are doing that
that you folks actually aren't even
seeing but uh
i see i seem to have attracted a
small cluster of
uh [ __ ] tonight
yes that was the last album roger was on
because it's basically a roger water
solo album with a guest appearance from
david and nick okay yeah that would be a
solid candidate for
train records then because the
the band that survived after that was
not the same band for all intents and
purposes
so you may you may or may not have
noticed miss wicked wolf i'm i'm
starting to be more selective about
which of your things i reply to
so when you keep poking me on the same
things i'm starting to glaze past them
get some new material
i'm sorry that was a little mean i i'm
not trying to be
but i might i might need
more water
uh
a friend of mine showed me some doctor
who knockoffs called the stranger
actually starring colin baker sophie
allred nicola bryant
and nick briggs one was good i haven't
heard of that huh
the mods deserve a tankard of water each
i agree
i wholeheartedly agree cheers
ah
a way of life i believe in with all my
heart is
don't waste your life bearing grudges
and live life
with love in your heart it's a good
motto i do my best
um i'm not going to say that i am
incapable of holding grudges
i don't hold many there are very very
few
and i don't hold someone a grudge just
because they hold one against me
because there are a number of people
who have been part of my life in the
past and no longer
are and i who i know
at least at some point in the past
uh harbored grudges i don't know if they
still do
they don't talk to me but i don't
begrudge people for holding a grudge
against me especially if i
understand why they did
but i am not above a grudge
i could count the number of grudges i've
ever held
on one hand and probably wouldn't even
need all my fingers
but um
don't plan to let them go
i'm sorry i don't i actually don't
like there's there's the
there's the general notion that letting
go of a grudge
somehow frees you and a way that's true
but i think that that depends how much
energy you're sinking into the grudge
so for me at this point the the few
grudges i still
hold i am not
i don't think energy into them
but i am not ever gonna forgive the
people in question
i can't and i won't and i'm okay with
that
i'm actually at peace with that fact
and whatever peace people tell me i
would have by
letting go and being forgiving
i'm at peace with the fact that i don't
have to
say i forgive you that's where i have
found peace
oh kirby in a hoodie okay first of all
love the name
love the icon you get a heart thank you
so much
i'm sorry the algorithm has forsooketh
you
oh uh and i'm sorry for the [ __ ] wits
your doctor who content rocks and though
i've now spoiled myself on a bunch of
episodes i'm excited to get back into it
i it honestly it's
a wonderfully touching
uh when people say that i i got them
either into something that they didn't
know before or back into something like
doctor who
when they took a break cause
even though i can get very complainy at
times
um i do love these things and i i love
it when other people love them
the only good grudges of the movie
disagree movie wasn't that good
as morrissey once saying uh beware bear
more grudges
than lonely high court judges
ah backstreet boys are the spice girls
ah probably backstreet
i've held grudges before because i just
wanted to shut that person out
because they hurt me in the past and i
don't want to let my defenses down
letting things go is very easily said
well so
without getting into
[Music]
a lot of details on this
because i won't
i don't even have that basis for some of
my gorgeous because
the grudge that i will probably hold for
the rest of my life
is against somebody who's dead
i did not kill them
let's just be very clear natural causes
and everything um
nor did i celebrate when they died
but this is someone who is literally
incapable of re-entering my life
they can't they're not here anymore
that still doesn't mean i have to
forgive them
i would honestly feel gross
saying or thinking
i forgive you for what you put me
through
that would feel
disgusting honestly
because for what this person put me
through
knowingly and
repeatedly
i do not have to forgive them
i will not forgive them
it is not my responsibility to forgive
them
if they had ever sought forget
forgiveness which they never did
maybe there would have been a
conversation to have had there
but knowing that they were unrepentant
for what they put me through
no
oop hold on first off
bookworm of the fandoms thank you
thank you very much you get a heart uh
have you heard of the big finish
chapter r and j from volume three of the
lives of captain jack
that's a lot of qualifiers no i have not
uh if so
have you heard of it nope uh stars river
song and jack harkness and in my opinion
is so good
see i will be nervous i'm glad to hear
that it's good and i believe you
um but that's the kind of setup where i
would be very nervous
um about bringing those two characters
together because
at least what i like about them they are
very
similar in
sort of outlook and characterization and
mentality in terms of the
flirty always having fun you know quick
with the snark
um here for the adventure kind of
vibe and when you have characters that
similar
they often have bad chemistry
because usually good
interaction between characters is
derived from the ways in which they
differ so when they're too
similar it it often doesn't work
but it sometimes can and it sounds like
they did there and that's good to hear
excuse me
um because you didn't dislike the carmel
master plan enough
and that book that actually did it it
was the writer's intention
that leela is the doctor
leela is the doctor's mom
have i mentioned how grateful i am that
they didn't get to do that
oh what ah
dear god oh
have you seen lupin iii the first the
cgi anime based on
uh one of possibly japan's most famous
oversea anime
italy has billboards with the main
character for god's sake i have not the
only loop in the third
thing that i've seen was cac castle of
cogliostro
and i saw that when i did uh my um
my ranking of all of hayao miyazaki's
films because that i think at the time
was the only one i hadn't seen
so that's the only loop in the third i
am familiar with
hamilton or greatest showman probably
greatest showman
do you like my icon uh
it has uh scar
friends and lecturers i actually can't
really make it out from here
um i would have to get much closer to
the screen
so i i don't know sorry
i'm in the middle of going through your
take two doctor who episode reviews just
wanted to say i'm enjoying your
perspective on capaldi's run
thank you once i finish
his run i i have plans for sort of a
master
video of my big overall
thoughts on
his time as the doctor and why or at
least a key aspect of
why he connects with me so
strongly i have uh
i i have thoughts
uh the bad bat show comes out in may
which i may actually try
um hopefully it can be understood
without knowing
clone wars because i'm not gonna watch
i'm not gonna barrel through clone
wars before then to catch up what why uh
sorry miss wicked wolf i find greatest
showman to be more fun
and i like the songs more
uh to be fair it apparently wasn't
explicit that leela
was his mom was more subtext on the
writer's head canon
same writer who wrote spare parts
weirdly enough
that is weird because spare parts is a
great discord
thank you carowind i will hop over there
in a minute
let's have to expect you to say hamilton
yes clearly you're
ah okay i gotta pop over the discord
which
gives me a chance to remind you all
that the council of geeks discord is a
thing
that exists it is a perk uh exclusive to
patreon supporters and
uh there's a channel there for the live
streams and is the one place that is
guaranteed that
whatever questions you ask will be
addressed um aside from
dropping the super chats here uh so give
me a minute and let me check
that so i had one
catching up on the what the frout
podcast um
you reach the scorpius netera scene you
know the one
oh that series has a taste for kink oh
my god it so does
so can the whole of firescape be read as
an extrapolation of dom
sub relationships dargo tell
tell him who his dad he is
[Laughter]
like honestly
if i was so inclined i could probably
make an argument
that fundamentally
farscape is about dom
subs and tops and bottoms with
scorpius being um you know like the
super dom
and aaron um
used to being a dom and trying to learn
how to be a switch
and um tiana's the brat
like i could i could go
way down a rabbit hole in this and look
folks if you're not
a watching farscape which is amazing
it's on amazon prime
and then listening to the what the frau
podcast that i do with jesse gender
excuse me where we go through every
episode of that one go at a time
and yes this subject of kink
has come up quite regularly
on that podcast for good reason
god i love farscape i love it so much
wanted to let you know my dog obviously
has great taste
because she happy barks when vera comes
on
ah thank you so much
oh that's adorable
okay um pop it on back to
the stream i think
where there we go there we go
uh
let's see
you just smiled innocently something
that i do
uh i don't know if i have an innocent
smile i don't think i do
okay thomas thank you very
very much for the super chat you get a
heart
have i played any games in the mist
series yes
i played the original back when it first
came out
i tried playing uh
riven which was the sequel
i didn't well i was gonna say i didn't
get very far in it
i don't know how far i got
um but i got stuck and this was back
when i was on dial-up so
looking up um
uh walk-throughs wasn't impossible but
it was a pain in the ass
and i so i ga i gave up on that one
i'm quite saddened as we approach the
oscars because unlike the previous two
times it happened i think
this will be a case of posthumous uh
acting oscar win
because of sympathy
possibly i don't know i don't even know
when the oscars are being held
actually
comic fun fact the early years of cyborg
story
he became a freaking cybernetic
planetoid comics are we
yes comics are weird
where can i find what the frel you
should be able to find it on most um
pod cast apps
um like apple podcasts and like the
the they're i actually house them on
libsyn but
i think it should be should be
on spotify as well the thing to remember
is you actually have to look for the
council of geeks podcast
because even though it's currently home
to the what the frail podcast the
podcast feed is council of geeks so
remember to look for that uh
remember the master and stream of the
shalka yeah i need to i need to talk
about that thing at some point
uh what they were doing with him kind of
reminds me of what they did with missy
and season
series 10. yeah i know i know and i'm
still
i'm still disappointed that they didn't
um
they didn't get they didn't do that for
longer
oh and i told jessie that you stole her
hearts yes i know you did
you've mentioned uh baftas are the
saturday coming
oscars are the 25th oh okay
cool just heard my first episode of what
the frel and it's amazing to hear your
dynamic with jesse you're both so great
thank you stephen i appreciate that
random question i'll give you a random
answer
uh but what do you think of whiplash
because i saw it recently i think it's
one of the best things ever i
have not seen it all the way through
i've seen clips
um i've definitely seen the clip of uh
um were you dragging or uh or were you
rushing
you know not my tempo uh so
but i haven't i haven't watched the
whole thing
good so i'm not sure how much longer i'm
gonna keep it going
i doubt it but have you seen the abcs of
death it's more trippy than scott
pilgrim
no it's not really my bag
to be completely honest noel clark is
getting the outstanding contribution to
british
cinema bafta this year and angley's
getting the fellowship award
huh so they
do they just announce in advance who's
winning
i don't watch the baftas so i i
legitimately don't know
i'mma bounce because i'm freaking tired
to hell
uh with time zones remember to be good
people
uh people chat yeah i'll try
thanks for stopping in i've seen attack
on titan i did about three episodes on
attack on titan and it did
not grab me
um it just yeah
i've been saying not my tempo since 1998
well yes you
would meg
i gave you a clue on who i was on
tick-tock and you said i figured that
was you yeah
yeah i remember uh
only announce annual awards okay all
right
have you ever written fan fiction about
any fandom no
i've waited i've written oh dear god
i've written quite a bit in general i've
never written fan fiction
i think largely because
i would get um
uppity about really being sure that i
captured the voices correctly
and worrying about doing it wrong and
then feeling restricted
by that yeah the idea of writing fan
fiction
really never appealed to me
okay oh
thank you randomness you
get a heart i'm one of those
people who can find some level enjoyment
in most
films until a friend showed me a film
called
things i was in legit pain that day
and that was more pleasant than the film
haven't heard of that one
do you read fan fiction not presently
when i was in college
i i feel like this is going to be very
revealing about who i
am uh or at least have been in the past
on
multiple levels so back around
when i was in college
i used to read uh dirty fan fiction
and get really annoyed
when when they would get things wrong
or or characters would it would behave
out of character
in basically reading smut
and critiquing the
the canosity of the portrayals
oh god
thoughts on the new little nas x song i
liked it but twitter went nuts oh you
think twitter went nuts you should see
what tick-tock
did with that thing it was
[Music]
bonkers um so
oh i arrive almost immediately drunken
slurring
i'm sure it had nothing to do with you
meg so
um
excuse me i like the little nausea song
but like i really love the video and
to quote my partner liz
it is uh the gayest thing that ever gade
and yeah
it's i really
really do do love how much he's just
owning all that stuff right now that's
a hat off to him seriously um
do you play any video games would you
consider playing a game if paid
sorry if you've answered this question
before um i do
um i do what i don't the the thing is if
if we're talking console i don't have
anything more current than a ps3
so i don't i don't game anything current
and my
and my computer is not up to stuff to
game
most current um pc games either
but i do have stuff and i have played
video games in the past and i have been
commissioned to play a video game once i
got commissioned
uh to play paper mario the thousand year
door
that review is up in the break room of
geeks
um so that actually
thank you bookworm you just made me
realize something so
um i'm gonna i'm gonna post a reminder
in
um
uh the community tab
um on uh
on the channel words
um
that i am gonna be um i'm
i i found an another game to stream
on twitch because i did the uh the
doctor who lonely assassins game and i
am i am going to cut together that
footage
and make a video out of it i just i had
other stuff i had to prioritize first
um but i'm going to play unavowed on my
twitch stream
starting tomorrow 11 a.m eastern
daylight
time and uh that's a that's a
2d point and click uh pixel art
adventure i'm
pretty sure my computer can handle that
but we'll find out
so um there you've reminded me to talk
about that thank you
can you whistle
yes i can i think the academy had to
choose between
nominating jared leto for little things
or putting the keith stanville
and supporting they made the right
choice if that was in fact the choice
then yes
yes they did because the little things
was
you were critiquing the canosity of porn
yes
yes i was i remember the one that made
me crack too
i got really pissed off when i read an
x-men dirty fanfic
and they just had rogue touching people
i was like
what no no you have to put in something
to counteract her
her powers first or she's got to be in
like full body latex what are you
doing so yes
do you think that ashes to ashes slash
life on mars could connect to doctor who
in some way
i haven't watched either of them so
don't know
ah
damn if the dog didn't come back no i
think he's past that he's actually quite
old he's like 13
and he's deaf so i actually can't call
him into the room either
um he is probably passed out on the
uh on the rug at a guess
for my birthday my friend and i are
either gonna see a quiet place too
if it's good i'm not hopeful
uh if not then we'll see cruella just to
make fun of it
valid more twitching yes yes gozer i be
twitching or something
i don't know um have you seen
nightcrawler if so thoughts the
um jake gyllenhaal movie
no no i haven't i've been meaning to
uh but i have not
i should wrap up soon
i also like honestly
debating the wisdom of doing
um two cans of water
this evening but um
i made my bed so i'm just rolling with
it now
can you whistle and hum at the same time
yes i can and i'm familiar with that
effect so hold on
let me see if i can get this i haven't
done it a little bit
[Music]
i've done better before
yeah i've done better uh
i'm sorry i am laughing at uh the latest
troll to just get
um banned
by the mods thank you again mods they're
all going on like you'll never be a real
woman
and i'm just back here like
i never said i was
but you don't know that and you don't
care cause you do not
care who i am as a person because you're
just
hateful little shits and i have not the
time
nor the inclination to burden
my thoughts or my time
with hateful little shits
you shall be flushed away and forgotten
evermore
ah
still waiting for a sid barrett by a pig
called crazy diamond
right oh yeah i'd pay to see that
do you have high hopes for doctor who
season 13 i
have hopes i don't know how high they
are but i have hopes
uh
uh the asmr voice
addiction is really showing i
you know what it is i i i when i
um
when i get in close to the mic it's
very difficult to resist
just lowering the voice a little bit
and seeing if
i can worm my way into your
hearts and minds
jesus uh
i'm curious as if the algorithm if
i'm honestly kind of curious if um
the youtube algorithm has done the same
thing to me that the tick tock algorithm
has been doing lately which is to
start pushing me in front of the eyes of
people
who are
frankly gonna hate me
because tick tock's been doing that to
me a lot it seems to either be dumping
me in front of people who
just don't like me and would never will
or
like nobody friggin sees my stuff
including the people who follow me on
there so
who knows anymore
uh
all right
so i am gonna i am gonna wrap it up i
think
ah i agree it seems a lot of people on
tick tock
end up on straight slash trump slash
uh ignorant for you page
yeah but honestly
the worst place to end up on tick tock
is
just any place where people not only
don't like you but they don't like you
and then they tag other people to pile
on you
because since they're tagging each other
the algorithm is going to keep
recommending
you to that kind of user that's like oh
for god's sake
but anyway gonna wrap it up
let's see
uh i
am going to be streaming on twitch
tomorrow
at 11
a.m eastern daylight time
and i will be on twitch on
thursday for the dnd
that will be on steven partridge
on twitch and that will be at 8
00 pm eastern daylight time
if i'm remembering correctly i think so
and yeah
we're gonna wrap it up there i hope
everybody
had a uh had a good time
i hope you have wonderful evenings
i hope you have a wonderful rest of the
week i hope you have
um less [ __ ]
in your day and in your life than i have
been dealing with lately
best wishes to all of you thank you
randomness
always nice to pop in have a good one
thank you very much
please remember that
you are beautiful you are valid
you are loved you are the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time
this council is adjourned
my cavity